[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres ramadan
dessert zum ramadan gibt's ja auf diese
traditionellen ich sage sich türkischen
den ramadan ist nicht nur türkisch
sondern international diese
traditionellen desserts wie zum beispiel
wackler war oder tool um bad müsse also
frittiertes spritzgebäck und ich habe
mir jetzt gedacht was natürlich auch
ganz typisch ist finde ich sind datteln
walnüsse orangenblüten wasser oder
rosenwasser und ich habe mir zum dessert
überlegt was einfach zu machen ist aber
auch leicht schmeckt also nicht ganz so
süß nicht mit zucker sirup getränkt und
deswegen werde ich jetzt erstmal einen
blechkuchen backen und macht ihn eben
mit datteln und walnüssen und des
rezeptes entwickelt sich jetzt noch also
ich will jetzt einfach ein blechkuchen
machen was man eben auch schon auf große
menge machen kann also gerade für das
ramadanfest daneben von amazon könnt ihr
dann zu bereiten habt was für viele
gäste und habt aber eben trotzdem wenig
arbeit damit es ist wirklich nicht so
aufwendig mit backwaren
ich mache jetzt erstmal den kuchen
später kommt noch eine creme brauch und
adecco das überlege ich mir dann während
der herstellung das entwickelt sich
jetzt wie gesagt einfach und japan
schauen wir einfach was dabei rauskommt
also dafür verwende ich viele sind
bereits zimmer waren 100 gramm zucker
200 gramm 1 200 gramm sonnenblumenöl 300
gramm mehr zwei teelöffel backpulver und
zwei teelöffel zimt und jeweils 150
gramm walnüsse und entsteint datteln bei
den datteln ist wirklich ganz wichtig
zuerst in steinen und dann abwägen und
da habe ich jetzt zwei verschiedene und
zwar hatte ich hier noch meine bio
datteln
die habe ich im supermarkt bekommen
vakuumiert die sind schon entsteint und
dann habe ich hier noch und das ist
meine lieblings datteln vom türkischen
supermarkt da bekommt er sie oft oder im
arabischen supermarkt das sind einfach
so richtig große fleischige dattel und
die sind echt super mega lecker und vor
allem riesengroß und ihr seht hier drin
und richtig schön süß eben auch und die
habe ich jetzt kurz selber entstand also
die habe ich habe auch relativ wenig
zucker wirklich genommen für die große
menge und ich nehme hier heute ein wenn
ihr kein iphone bekommt einer ist ein
salziges getränken
gut getränk dann könnt ihr auch einfach
etwas verflüssigten joghurt buttermilch
nehmen aber dann gebt einfach nur eine
prise salz zu ordern ist einfach schon
ein einziges getränk deswegen passt
jetzt hier wirklich perfekt ok dann
starte ich jetzt hier direkt ihr könnt
ein handrührgerät nehmen oder eine
küchenmaschine mit schneebesen dann kann
ich jetzt zuerst mal die eier hier in
die rührschüssel geben gemeinsam mit dem
zucker und jetzt wirklich einfach schön
cremig rühren und in der zwischenzeit
kann ich hier schon mal die trockenen
zutaten vermischen
das heißt mehl mit backpulver und zimt
das wird gleich verrührt
[Musik]
und dann werde ich auch gleich die
walnüsse mal und die dafür zu klein
das mache ich dann einfach im mixer
[Musik]
ich lass dir so ein bisschen leicht kopf
und die daten führe ich jetzt hier mit
dem 1
so geht's einfach nicht bekommen sind
vor allem richtig schön zerkleinert
[Musik]
das ist alles richtig schön sagt
kleinert guckt mal ein ei russell perry
dann kommt hier jetzt das rein mit zu
einer masse die dattel masse
[Musik]
die wahl müsse die habe ich jetzt
wirklich nur ganz grob zerkleinert so
hat man gleich noch ein bisschen bis und
hier das mehl wenn es etwas klumpig ist
dann bitte 7 bei mir ist es wirklich
super fein
ich verwende auch meisten instant mehr
zum backen gerade bei urteilen bist wird
bei hefeteig bei mir beträgt nicht und
das kommt jetzt hier alles rein und
jetzt wirklich nur noch ganz kurz
vermischen bis sich alles verbunden hat
oder ist das schon fertig
[Musik]
wird hier den bug haben schön oft gleich
größe ausgezogen
da kommt die masse jetzt hinein
dies sieht und riecht jetzt schon
richtig gut aus also sieht gut aus und
dreht gut ich habe sie bisher noch nicht
probiert also ich weiß nicht wie es
schmeckt aber ich denke nicht so süß so
eine schöne leichter süße durch die
datteln wenig zucker der euro dabei
[Musik]
das war jetzt ist alles schön glatt
gestrichen der kuchen kommt in den ofen
und ich mache mir gedanken über den
weiteren verlauf des grund sein
[Musik]
der kuchen ist schon gebacken ich habe
jetzt auch kühl gestellt also der war
schon abgekühlt aber jetzt nochmal einen
kühlschrank damit er richtig kalt wird
hier mache ich jetzt schon mal die masse
die ich oben drauf bröseln möchte also
nach der creme
ich habe hier 200 gramm walnüsse die
sind von meiner schwiegermutter aus der
türkei hat sie alle extra für uns
gesammelte geschält und dann mitgebracht
echt prozess und wir haben die einfach
einfach com ihr verhalten sei nämlich
länger 100 gramm butter 150 gramm zucker
und 200 gramm engelshaar das bekommt ihr
im türkischen oder arabischen supermarkt
aus engelshaar macht man ganz gerne
desserts ist einfach eine teigware und
dies wirklich super vor allem weil sie
gleich in kombination mit der butter und
dem zucker schön knusprig wird also ein
bisschen karamellisiert die walnüsse ist
ein kleiner ich jetzt group deswegen
mache ich das auch hier mit einem messer
[Musik]
also wirklich schön gebockt sagt nein
hat jetzt kommen die hier in eine pfanne
wählt die pfanne bitte groß genug aus
denn es kommen gleich alle zutaten rein
die kann erklärt schon mal an machen und
etwas kosten lassen
auch mit dem hoher hitze und jetzt
nämlich noch das engelshaar und schneit
es auch klein
[Musik]
mit dem ich jetzt die butter dazu ist
das ganz warm empfangen boden
den zucker gebe ich auch dass zu der
darf nämlich auch gleich mit
karamellisieren
es ist einfach hier die butter zucker
muss mischungen ein bisschen berühren
ist leicht karamellisiert dafür ist
jetzt schon lecker
[Musik]
das ist hier schon ein bisschen resten
lassen karamellisieren lassen
den duft genießen denn es richtig super
lecker ich glaube ich muss es noch
abrunden
mit etwas zimt
wir ergänzen in der zutatenliste einen
viertel teelöffel z
ja
ach was soll der geiz für mandanten
das riecht einfach gerade wie gebrannte
mandeln gebrannte bahn ist ok jetzt ist
engel war nicht vergessen das kommt
jetzt hier mehr dazu
wie gesagt wer deine pfanne die groß
genug ist ich habe sie wieder zu klein
gewählt da ich die eine zuschauerin die
jedes mal das drunter schreibt ich bin
mir jedes mal so die große fahne wenn
das spülen
ja
hört ihr das schön dass karamellisiert
wie schön es knusprig android
[Musik]
so wie die masse jetzt aus schön
karamellisiert und ich gebe es jetzt
hier einfach auf eine folie zum abkühlen
ihr könnt das ganze auch wenn ihr es
vermischt habt im topf und jetzt nicht
so lange am herd stehen volt im backofen
karamellisieren einfach auch so auf
einem backblech mit backpapier aber
aufpassen dass es nicht verbrennt das
lasse ich jetzt schön abkühlen und kann
in der zwischenzeit schon mal die sahne
creme machen
die creme könnte jetzt mit quark machen
mit frischkäse ich nehme jetzt schmandt
weil ich stand einfach auch super lecker
findet also einfach eins zu eins
ersetzen wenn ihr jetzt gespannt habt
oder nicht mögt ich nehme dafür 400
gramm sahne 400 gramm und etwas wein
extrakt und sonderbar zum streit
schlagen also wirklich kein puderzucker
sonderfahrt ist ja auch schon leicht
gesüßt und dann habe ich wirklich nur
leicht gesüßte creme habe den boden und
die deko oben drauf und ich denke es
reicht auf jeden fall von der süße ich
nehme jetzt die sahne die kommt in die
rührschüssel wenn ihr frischkäse
mascarpone oder quark nehmt dann verödet
zuerst einmal die tat denn die sind
meist einfach etwas fester gespannt ist
ein relativ fein und flüssig also nicht
flüssig aber halt einfach geschmeidig
den brauche ich nicht geschmeidig rühren
aber alles andere chance und dann erst
die sahne dazugeben
vanilla extrakt ist das schöne an meinem
mann in der extrakt es wirklich aus der
puren vanilleschote gewonnen und einfach
mit etwas zucker haltbar gemacht und da
ist deswegen kein alkohol drin und wird
aber auch nicht schlecht man hat
wirklich das schöne vanillearoma bzw
sogar vanille konzentrat und die haben
nichts künstliches mit dabei jetzt kann
ich hier alles kurz verrühren
sun abfällig immer um habe es hier drin
und da kann ich jetzt einfach mit dazu
geben
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier die creme schön auf
den kalten tortenboden streichen da
immer schön darauf achten dass der
tortenboden auch wirklich kalt ist
ansonsten müsst euch nämlich die creme
weg hin zur traditionellen ramadan
desserts werden oft nicht so viele
früchte verwendet oder gar keine
frischen früchte weil die sich wirklich
wenn man sie zubereitet über mehrere
tage halten auch barack obama zum
beispiel oder cottbus alles was so mit
zuckersirup getränkt ist hält sich
natürlich auch und das heißt man kann es
immer einmal gut vorbereiten und dann
eben fertig stellen und hat es dann
einfach schon da
hier nehme ich jetzt auch keine frischen
früchte weil das dass er sich jetzt auch
wirklich schon vor drei vier tage hält
also es wird sich länger halten wenn ich
jetzt keine frische sahne und keinen
schwandorf zu verwenden würde
aber das macht natürlich den kuchen
extrem lecker hoffe ich zumindest
probiert habe ich so nicht
[Musik]
ok so perfekt muss man es nicht machen
es beruhigt ok und da kommt jetzt die
mafa drauf hast du dich schon probiert
oh mein gott
nicht so süß knusprig gramsci ober
kracher und das könnte jetzt hier
einfach oben drauf
[Musik]
ach ist das schön so schnell und einfach
das überlege ich mir noch ob ich was als
deko zubereitet
jedenfalls kommt der kuchen also diese
schnitte so lange in den kühlschrank und
ich überlegte was aber so wäre schon
perfekt aber ich glaube so eine sonne
dachte so eine schoko daten obendrauf
das rundet glaube ich dass das jetzt ist
der kuchen durch gekühlt und ich kann
ihnen raus lösen dafür nämlich ein
torten retter und ziehe den kompletten
kuchen
er ist schwer hier herunter damit ich
gleich nicht meiner back folie schneide
löse ich die bank folie jetzt weg das
einfach umschlagen und strother
wegziehen dann den rahmen lösen
ich glaube ich schneide ist ich weiß
noch nicht ob ich in dreiecke schneiden
denn ich habe jetzt gesehen
eigentlich wollte ich ja selber datteln
mit schokolade überzogen dann ist mir
eingefallen wir haben über mit
schokolade überzogene datteln leider
gerade nur noch weiße da der murat alle
anderen aufgegessen hat und hier haben
wir sogar noch pralinen diese mit
dunkler schokolade daher das sind auch
datteln
ich glaube ich nehm tatsächlich jetzt
einfach die zum dekorieren
okay ich mache ich setze ich glaube ich
schneide quadrate quadrat
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt hier die sehr
wunderschöne praline und stecke sie hier
noch so drauf
morath willste probieren ja unbedingt
ist nicht so lasst uns nicht im garten
zu tun hat weiß dass der nächste tour
ist deswegen habe ich ja ich bin gerade
dabei die nase streichen so nebenher
schwer
ja und ich weiß nicht wo sein vater die
leiterin getan da steht sie doch tue
sich aber nicht gerade so hörst du die
fassade gestrichen ich beschreibe ich
was sage ich habe den ganzkörperanzügen
ach so ok alles was kannst du dir noch
eine gabel kurz holen ja ok sieht aus
nach sauerkraut entschluss wird man
ramadan dass er
ich richte jetzt gleich noch schön an
ich bin hier noch nicht fertig bin nur
hier fertig aber dadurch dass du diese
dunklen alle aufgegessen hat und die
hellen jetzt optisch nicht so gut passen
ja übrigens so ok dann probierte ja ok
warum hat schon eine gabel weniger hand
ist welche und dann hochheben
ich denke solange weiter gegen
überrascht und war folgendes baum
überrascht wenn man so orientalische
spezialitäten macht dann sind sie meist
zu süß
ich weiß dass alle orient aus wenn ich
denken sicher halte wer fasten und dann
kommen genau kann ich mir das ist zwar
süß aber nicht so arg dass es sagt nur
ein stück runter
okay okay ich hatte nicht gefunden
das ist wollte schöne reise habe ich das
dieses mal muss drauf yaacool walnüsse
von meiner mama aus der türkei aus zehn
hat sich für uns extra geschält und
mitgebracht und evakuiert
das rezept gerne nach backen wenn ihr
kein so großes blech backen wollen
die einfach in meiner app die zutaten
herunterrechnen auf eure backform größe
ihr könnt das ganze auch rund packung
zum beispiel gibt dann einfach nur runde
backform an mit 20 29 26 zentimetern
haben mich hat sie auch schon ruft
gebacken
macht sie das tun ihren ding hier und
machen backt oder man aufgrund meiner
familie etwas geschmerzt damit sagen
also macht gut macht besser haltet eure
man bei laune und backt den einfachen
pass auf dass du die scheiben nicht
einschlägt achten kurve
[Musik]